Transcriber: rana heloun
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
مرحبا .
كان يا مكان بقديم الزمان وسالف العصر
والأوان لحتى كان.
باحث في النفس البشرية قرر أن يجري تجربة
أتى بمجموعة من المتطوعين وقال لهم:
ستدخلون غرفة وتكتشفوا ما هو المُجسم
الموجود داخل الغرفة.
ولكن بثلاثة شروط.
أول شرط هو ستضعون جميعكم عصابة للعين
لكي لا تروا.
والشرط الثاني سيكون هناك
وقت محدد.
والشرط الثالث أريد قرار جماعي.
الجميع سيُخبرني ما هو نوع الحيوان
الذي في الغرفة.
وبالفعل تمت التجربة،
غُمِضت الأعين ودخلوا المتطوعين.
كل شخص منهم لمس جزء من مُجسم الحيوان.
قُرع الجرس وانتهى الوقت المُحدد
وخرج المُشاركين.
بدأت المرحلة الثانية وهي النقاش
والتوصل لقرار جماعي لاكتشاف نوع الحيوان.
قال أحدهم أنا لمست ناب عاجي وقاسي.
فغالباً الحيوان إما فيل أو وحيد القرن.
قال آخر أنا لمست ذنب طويل عليه حراشف
فغالباً الحيوان تمساح، مالذي تقوله؟
وقال الشخص الثالث أنا لمست رجل ثخينة جداً
وكبيرة بالكاد قدرت أن أعانقها،
فغالباً هو فيل أو فرس النهر.
وقال آخر أنا لمست جسم ضخم جداً جداً،
فأنا أُرجح أن يكون فرس نهر.
حتى قال آخر شخص أنا لمست منقار.
فدُهش الجميع.
هذا يعني أنّه طائر ضخم جداً،
فربما هو العنقاء.
بدؤوا يتشاجرون فيما كلٍ منهم متمسك برأيه.
حصل عنف لفظي بدلاً من إيجاد الحل.
قُرع الجرس وانتهى الوقت
ولم يجدوا الجواب.
لم يعودوا يُريدوا أن يعرفوا ما هو الحيوان،
ذهبوا إلى صاحب التجربة وطلبوا منه
أن يخبرهم فقط من هو على حق.
“لم نَعد نريد أن نعرف“.
فأخبرهم أنّ لا أحد على حق ولا أحد على خطأ
فكل واحد لديه جزء من الجواب
ولو جمعتم أجوبتكم كنتم ستعرفون الجواب.
فدخلوا الغرفة وشاهدوا مُجسم
لنوع من الديناصورات الطائرة.
إذاً كل واحد منهم كان يصف وصفاً صحيحاً،
ولكنّهم لم يتناقشوا ليعرفوا ما هو الحل .
استخدمتُ هذه القصة القصيرة تمهيداً
للموضوع الذي أريد أن أتكلم عنه اليوم.
والذي هو التقبّل.
اسمحوا لي أن أُفرق بين التقبّل والقبول.
القبول هو شعورنا اتّجاه أي شخص
نواجهه خلال حياتنا.
بينما التقبّل هو أن نقبل
أفعاله وأفكاره ومشاعره.
نحن كبشر كُنا أقوياء أو ضعفاء مجازاً.
غالباً نعيش ظروف غير مناسبة
ويمكن أن تحدث لنا مواقف خارجة عن إرادتنا.
ونضطر أن نتواجد في مكان عمل
أو دراسة غير مريح.
هنا يأتي دور التقبُّل ليحل هذه المُعضلة
ولكي نستغرق وقتنا لنفهم ما نمُر به.
وعلى هذا الأساس نقرر إذا كنا سنستمر أم لا
أو أن نوافق أم لا.
سأشارككم بقصة حدثت معي قديما
وتركتني أبقى في نفس المكان لمدة من الزمن.
عملت كمتطوعة في مركز مُجتمعي
في العام 2009.
عملت أنا وصديقتي المُقربة،
أترون كم هي الحياة وردية؟
أنا وصديقتي في نفس المكان!
في مركز مجتمعي،المكان الذي يعني الكثير لي.
بعد فترة من الزمن أصبحنا
نعاني من حساسيات العمل.
ولم نعرف كيف نتعامل معهم بالشكل الصحيح
فتراكموا مع الوقت مما أحدث شرخ في العلاقة.
وشعرت أنّ صديقتي تتغير شيئاً فشيء،
وبعد فترة من الزمن شعرت بأنّ كل الفريق
يعمل ضدي وأصبحت منبوذة.
وفي الحقيقة أنا كنت أشاركهم هذا النبذ
فقد ساعدتهم وعزلت نفسي.
أصبح الوضع متوتراً وضغط دائم
وأصبحت أذهب للعمل من غير رغبة.
وأصبح أدائي في العمل مُعدم.
بقيت على هذه الحالة وأنا أكابر على نفسي
ولا أعترف بأنّي ضعيفة.
وأصبحت بعد مدة لا مبالية وساخرة.
حتّى أنّني لم أقبل أي دعم، لا من أصدقاء
ولا من أهل ولا من أعضاء الفريق نفسه.
لأنّني عدّيت نفسي شخص قوي ببساطة.
بعد مُدة انضمّ زميل جديد للعمل.
وبالرغم من الأسلاك الشائكة التي وضعتُها
حولي لأنّي فقدتُ الثقة.
سألني لماذا تعزلين نفسك؟
لماذا أنتي مُصّرة على لعب دور الضحية
ولكن بِنَفَس الجلّاد؟
في الحقيقة صدمني
ولم أعد قادرة على التكلّم.
عُدت للمنزل وبقيت طَوال الليل أُفكر
أنّه في الغالب مُحق.
بدايةً هو لا يعرفني أي لا يملك حكم مسبق
لأنّه شخص جديد.
وأيضاً لا يعلم مالذي حدث،
فما قاله كان مُجرد رأي حيادي.
رأيه الحيادي جعلني أُفكر
طوال الليل وأُكلم نفسي.
وقفت أمام المرآة وكلمت نفسي وقلت لها:
لست أعرف نفسي،
أنا أكره نفسي جداً في هذه الحالة،
وأحب نفسي كثيراً، متعبة جداً وضعيفة
ولكّني أستحق أن أقف مجدداً.
تعمقت في التفاصيل أكثر
طبعاُ وأنا أبكي.
وقررت تقسيم ما علي فعله لمهام صغيرة
كي أستطيع إنجازها،
على حسب قدرتي لأن طاقتي مُعدمة
والتوتر دائم ولا رغبة لي بإنجاز أي عمل.
ذهبت للعمل في اليوم التالي وطلبت منهم
أن يسلموني أي عمل إداري،
لأنُّني لست مستعدة للتعامل مع فريق بعد.
وبالفعل بدأت بعمل إداري، وأعتقد أنّه ربما
لأني اتخذت وقتي وخفّ ضغط العمل مع مجموعة..
فأبدعت بالعمل الإداري وأصبحت تعود ثقتي
قليلاً وبدأت أعود لنفسي.
وبعد سنة استلمت إدارة مركز مُجتمعي.
وبعد سنة أخرى استلمت قسم، وبعد سنة ثالثة
استلمت المشروع في كامل سوريا.
المُضحك واللذيذ الذي أتذكره،
أنّه في هذه الثلاث السنوات
التي لملمت فيها شتاتي،
أو سنوات دمي ودموعي وابتسامتي.
كنت دائماً اسمع جملة من الناس في مُحيطي،
يقولون لي أنتي شخص جيد
وبعض الناس يقولون لي أنتي شخص مُذهل.
في البداية كُنت أنزعج كثيراُ
مع أنّ الكلام جميل ويجب أن يُعجبني،
ولكنّني كنت أفكر كيف أنّني كنت
أُظهر نفسي للناس على صورة وحش.
أو أنّ الناس هكذا تُظهرني
وأنا سمحت بهذا.
وبعد مُدة أصبحت أشاركهم بحس الدعابة وابتسم
وأقول: هذه أنا من قبل والآن وكل القصة
أنّي كنت مُنعزلة ولا أكثر ولا أقل.
في نفس السياق فكرت في كم استطعت أن أغير
من نفسي وأتقبل ضعفي حتى صعدت شيئاً فشيء.
فكرت في كيفية استخدامنا لهذا التقبل الذي
قد يكون في حال قبلنا استخدامه..
أحد مفاتيح حياتنا الذهبية.
يوجد دوائر تأثير بحياة أي أحد منّا،
أنا، أنتِ، أنتَ، أنتم.
أول دائرة تأثير هي نحن،
مثلاً: أنا أي الفرد.
في الغالب نختلف في الصفات
أو الأفكار أو الشكل.
ولكن كل شخص منّا لديه ما يُميّزه.
جملة أحبها كثيرا:
كلٌ منّا جميل بطريقة ما.
وهنا الجمال لا يتعلق فقط
إمّا بالشكل أو بالمضمون.
هو خليط صفات مميزة لكل شخص منّا.
والأذكى هو أن نقدر أن نستخدم
أدواتنا بشكلٍ صحيح.
لذلك هنا سأؤكد وأركز أنّه على كل شخص
أن يُكبّر صورة البطل داخله.
وأن يُخفِف صورة الوحش
أو أن لا يدع أحد يرسمه بصورة الوحش.
الفكرة أيضاً من الفرد أنّ مُعظمنا غالباً،
وإذا أسقطوها على نفسكم وفكرتم معي بصوت عال
تجدوا أنّ مُعظمنا لديه نقاط ضعف
ونقاط قوة.
وماذا نفعل جميعنا في نقاط القوة؟
نستعرضها ونتباهى بها.
ولكن نقاط الضعف للأسف ندفنها أعمق ما يمكن
ولا نعترف بها.
وهذا ما يجعلنا نبقى في نفس المكان
مثلما حصل معي سابقاً لفترة من الزمن.
لهذا الأجدى من ذلك هو أن نحب نقاط الضعف
لأنّه شئنا أم أبينا هم جزء منّا ببساطة.
ونحاول أن نغيّرهم.
ويجب أن نعلم جيداً أن بعض هذه النقاط
قابلة للتغيير ،
وجزء منها سيبقى في سُبات طويل
ولكن ضمن للسيطرة،
وجزء آخر لن يتغير وسيلازمنا طوال حياتنا،
ولكن سنستطيع التعامل معه بشكل أوعى
لنكسبه لجانبنا ولا يصبح ضدنا.
فيما يخص الدائرة الأكبر من الفرد
التي هي الأسرة والأصدقاء.
هنا نجد أنّه ضمن الأسرة الواحدة يوجد تشابه
واختلاف ونجد آراء وأفكار ومورثات واحدة.
ورغم أنّنا من نفس البيئة ونفس التربية
ونفس الثقافة،
هذا لا يعني أنّ جميعنا يجب أن نملك
نفس الرأي اتجاه أي موضوع ما.
هنا يمكن أن تحدث مواقف حادّة أو حسّاسة،
ولكن ما يلعب دور صمّام الأمان
في هذه الدائرة هو العاطفة.
تربطنا بعائلتنا وبأصدقائنا عاطفة.
هذه العاطفة هي ما يخفف الآثار
التي من الممكن أنّها حادة كثيراً،
حادّة اتجاه أي خلاف بالرأي
والسلوك والأفكار.
هنا تُصبح العاطفة الدرع الحامي.
لهذا من الطبيعي أن نجد في عائلة ما
الأخت تُحب كرة القدم،
فيما الأخ يُحب تصميم الأزياء،
شخص مجموع درجاته عالٍ،
لكنّه يريد أن يختص في الفنون الجميلة.
شخص يمتلك مهارات ولا يريد أن يختار
مهنة الآباء والأجداد.
ما يُميز هذه المنطقة أنّها مساحة آمنة،
فرجاءً دعوها مساحة آمنة.
ونحن كأهل أو كأصدقاء ليس من الضروري
أن نكون نسخ عن بعضنا لأنّه ليس صحيح.
وكأهل يرجى ألّا تضعوا قوالب جاهزة للأبناء
ودعوهم يعيشون مساحتهم الآمنة بحرية.
الدائرة الثالثة والأكبر
هي المُجتمع والآخرين.
وهنا أريد أن أضرب مثالاً لنفكر سويةً.
في حال رسمتُ خط مستقيم ومائل على الشاشة.
ماذا يُمكن أن تُكمَلوه ليُصبح شكل مناسب.
أحدكم سيرسم قلب،
وآخر سيرسم وردة.
وآخر سيكمله ليصبح مثلث.
برأيكم ما الصحيح وما الخطأ؟
من صاحب الشكل الأصح؟
لا يوجد صح أو خطأ.
لأنُّ كل شخص منّا يفكر حسب تجاربه السابقة
وكيف هو يرى هذا الخط المائل.
وهذا الاختلاف لا يُفسد للود قضية.
وبذكر الود لنتعامل مع التقبّل
أثناء الكوارث ..
كمفهوم حاوي يجمعنا.
ماذا أعني بكلمة (يجمعنا)؟
غالباً عندما تحدث مصائب أو أزمات أو كوارث،
المُزاح الذي يُضحكنا،
مثل بأي نوع من اللحوم يُطبخ الطعام،
ولأي محافظة تعود أكلة ما،
تُصبح هذه النكات أثناء الكوارث
مصادر للنزاع.
وأحياناً يُمكن أن يتطور لنزاع جسدي.
لأنّه غالباً في الأزمات أو الكوارث
أو لنأخذ الحرب كمثال.
أيّ شخص منّا يعود للانتماء الأصغر فالأصغر.
فنجد في البلد الواحد أبناء المدينة الواحدة
أصبحوا ضد المدن الأخرى.
أبناء شارع ضمن هذه المدينة
ضد الشوارع الأخرى.
وكل حارة ضد الحارات الأُخرى.
وكل بناء في هذه الحارة ضد الأبنية الأُخرى.
وممكن أن نصل للأسف أنّه في نفس المنزل
أنا ومن بعدي الطوفان.
لماذا وصلنا لهذه النقطة؟
هذا نتيجة الخوف الناتج عن الكارثة
بغض النظر عن نوع الكارثة.
شيئ آخر مهم هو عدم تقبّل الاختلاف
إلّا كمفهوم إقصائي.
غالباً عندما نواجه مُصيبة،
فشعورنا والضغط علينا يجعلنا نعتقد
أنّ أي شخص لا يوافقنا هو ضدّنا.
وهكذا نبدأ الخوف من بعضنا شيئاً فشيْ.
ويتراكم شيء ما في القلب ولا نعرف لماذا.
الفجوات والمساحات بيننا تَكبُر
ونضيع،
ونسقط مثل حبات اللؤلؤ..
(أُغنية للمطربة جوليا بطرس)
(بلحظة بتلاقينا رجعنا وحدو الحب بيبقى معنا
وطن وغربة)
يجب أن تُصفقوا لي لأعرف إذما يجب عليّ
الاتجاه إلى الفن.
بعدما نسقط مثل حبات اللؤلؤ
مع أغنية جوليا،
مثل المُغمضة عينيه، لديه جزء من الحقيقة
ويعتقد أنّه الجزء الوحيد.
ونبتعد عن بعضنا خائفين.
هنا يُهمني أن أؤكد أنّ الاختلاف ليس وصمة.
وكل منّا يخوض حروب داخلية تكفيه
ليس من الضروري أن نعلم بها.
لهذا يفضل ألّا نتعب قلوب بعضنا.
في الختام، برأيي الشخصي في الحياة
لا شيء بالمُطلق.
كل شيء نسبي، لهذا من الطبيعي
أن نستقبل ونُرسل ونتعامل،
ونحسّ اتجاه أي أحد في تباين عن بعضنا.
طرف الخيط هو التقبل،
لكن كيف نمسك به؟
نمسكه عندما يبدأ كل شخص منّا من نفسه.
يتقبل نفسه ويتقبل الآخر.
وتذكروا دائماً إذا كان طرف الخيط
هو التقبّل فالخيط كلّه هو نحن.
فكونوا مع بعض وليس ضد بعض.
لدي مقولة أحبها كثيراً..
“كلٌ منّا يملك جزء من الحقيقة...
والطريقة التي أعمل بها ليست
الطريقة الوحيدة الصحية...
هنالك طرق أخرى لكل منها جانب من الصحة.”
بتاريخ 11/11/2011 كنت فاقدة نفسي
وأسبح في الحضيض.
واليوم بتاريخ 11/11/2021،
أنا من بين المئات أحد العشرة المُتحدثين
في (تيد اكس العظمة ) في سوريا.
لكي أصل إلى هنا وكثير من الإنجازات السابقة
في حياتي،
اكتشفت خلطة سحرية تُدعى التقبّل
والتي كانت جوازي للعبور.
والآن حان دوركم،
أمستعدين؟
شكراً.